foreign
's in Seattle hey Brian how are you
not bad how you guys doing better than
we deserve sir what's up in your world
uh so I got a divorce about a year ago
and I have full custody of me of my
children and according to the courts
like exos me just under seventy thousand
dollars and it became obvious I was
never going to see a dime of it so I
kind of gave up on that uh but I really
needed the money I was a few days away
from missing a house payment and my
parents figured out what was going on
and they bailed me out
um and I'm beyond grateful I'm doing way
better than I deserve and I have a paid
for home now as a result of it and right
now though the the thing that the
question is that she's not going to sign
the quit claim deed and I just I don't
want to stir up any problems oh too late
I keep the peace too late
she has a court order she has a court
order
yeah she's gonna sound quite claim dude
she's got about 20 seconds Ready Set Go
this is ridiculous it's ridiculous
let me just tell you let me tell you
your wife your ex-wife is not very smart
she does not want to be in contempt of
court they put people in jail for that
crap
yeah so here's what we're gonna do you
have your attorney
call her old attorney
and tell him you have five minutes to
get this signed or we're going to file
with the judge and the judge is going to
put her in jail for contempt to court
after he tells her to sign it if she
doesn't sign it instantly judges don't
screw around with this stuff they're
kind of bossy that's why they call them
judges
the the thing that I'm I'm kind of
worried about is that she's kind of a
high conflict and I just so am I put the
kids in the middle of a high conflict
the kids aren't in the middle of it kids
ain't got nothing to do with it yeah
chick needs to sign one piece of paper
that the court told her she had to sign
it's not high conflict this is how
stupid
yeah your kids are in the middle of
nothing
just just she just needs to be smacked
into next week metaphorically speaking
also you said you have full custody what
does that relationship look like with
your kids and her
uh I I try to make sure that she gets
her visitation so she has you know
supervised visits and stuff like that
but that's fine um
yeah that doesn't even enter into it
you're abiding by the court order only
visitation aren't you
yeah and she has missed two of three on
the I mean she's missed the other two
number one 70 grand no show number two
sign the quit claim deed gonna show baby
you owe your parents this
you're scared of her aren't you
a little bit
[Laughter]
I can't blame you really because I think
this one is a test pilot for a broom
factory man
well and as a parent I do I do feel the
empathy of wanting to protect your kids
but I think it's important to do with
the kids this is God he don't want to
deal with her she is way too much
trouble to deal with and that's why
she's the ex that's why they call them
exes
yeah but dude you've got to get your
house this is not going to go well you
think it's going to get better by not
dealing with it it's going to get worse
conflict conflict delayed is conflict
Amplified Dr John deloney says
yeah it's going to get bigger isn't it
so splinter under the skin it's kind of
fester and then you're gonna have to
have your hand cut off because it's
gangrene
you got to deal with it you got to deal
with it it's an algae but you got to
deal with it
well and I think this is actually a way
to protect your kids I think that
dealing with this is going to actually
give you a little bit more control over
this relationship versus dragging it out
for years like this needs to be cut off
this needs to be done but here's the
thing it's not getting to do with your
kids kids aren't even in the equation
I'm not going to talk about the kids
about it it's not kids stuff it's adult
stuff
you just be sweet to the kids and you be
sweet to them when you drop her off you
don't run her down to the kids even if
she is a twerp you're still not going to
run her down the kids you just speak
highly of their mom and you just be a
good man a man of nobility who enforces
the law
and the law is the law said the judge
said with the hammer on the gavel
sign the quit claim deed have your
attorney contact her attorney today dude
do not put this off you have got to deal
with this it's going to get worse it's
not going to get better